אז מה זה Qiskit
Qiskit זה ערכת פיתוח תוכנה בקוד פתוח
לעבודה עם מחשבים קוונטיים
ברמה של circuits
אלגוריתמים ומודולי יישומים. ערכת ה-SDK הזאת
מאפשרת לכל אחד לתכנת על מחשבים קוונטיים אמיתיים מ
הלפטופ שלו. בשתי שורות קוד אפשר לגשת
למספר מערכות קוונטיות שנעות בין מוליכים-על
ועד qubits של יונים לכודים. רוצה לדמות התנהגות
של מחשב קוונטי? פשוט שנה שורה אחת של קוד
ותדמה את ה-quantum circuits שלך על ה
סימולטור בעל הביצועים הגבוהים שלנו. Qiskit הוא כלי שמשתמשים בו עשרות
אלפי אנשים ברחבי העולם שמנסים
לבנות את העתיד. בין אם אתה חוקר, מפתח
או סתם רוצה להתחיל
ל-Qiskit יש מספר
תכונות זמינות לצרכים שלך
שמאפשרות לכל אחד לעשות דברים
כמו לבנות את ה-quantum circuit הראשון שלך
להריץ אלגוריתמים קוונטיים חוצי-תחומים
ולחקור תופעות קוונטיות בסיסיות
אולי עכשיו זה הזמן המושלם להיכנס לעניין בעצמך
ולמצוא את כל הכלים שאתה צריך
כולל מחשבים קוונטיים אמיתיים
וה-SDK דרך Qiskit
וקהילה שתשמח לקבל אותך
ולענות על כל שאלה שיש לך בדרך
אתה יכול להתחיל היום
בـQiskit